[Musique]
c'est celle qui remettait en question
l'origine africaine de des homininés
d'origine africaine de notre séparation
avec le chimpanzé donc cette cette
théorie elle a été publiée dans plos one
qui est un journal
un comité de lecture avec un impact
factor qui en a qui en tout cas dans
notre profession inspire le respect donc
a priori pas pas de quoi s'inquiéter
mais là sur cette origine européenne
il ya quand même des choses qui sont
très discutables donc déjà sur quoi se
base sur quel matériel se base cette
soi-disante origines européennes
contrairement à l'origine africaine
qu'on admettez jusqu'à présent elle se
base sur une mâchoire donc une mâchoire
inférieure d'un grand singe qui a été
découvert en grèce et l'analyse de cette
mâchoire donc aurait démontré que
qu'elle partageait des caractères avec
les hominidés et que avec les homininés
pardon et qu'en parallèle cette mâchoire
serai vieille de sept millions d'années
ce qui en ferait l'équivalent voire même
la rendrait un peu plus ancienne que
celle de sahel entre opus donc toumaï
donc il serait plus ancien que le plus
ancien des homininés connue en afrique
et donc à partir de ce matériel
les auteurs en ont conclu que du coup
les homininés sont apparus non pas en
afrique comme on le pensait mais en
europe
et ça ça peut faire ça peut faire penser
à quelque chose qui aurait dû fondement
puisque on on sait qu'en europe on a un
très très bon registre fossile des
grands singes il y avait beaucoup de
grands singes en europe il ya 7 millions
d'années et avant ça même les grands
sages ont disparu relativement récemment
d'europe donc
ce il est possible que à l'intérieur de
cette diversité on est vu apparaître les
premiers hominidés donc maintenant quels
sont les problèmes selon moi avec 7 avec
cette théorie c'est que déjà le matériel
de base donc la mâchoire n'est pas très
joli spécimen
c'est un spécimen qui est très usés et
particulièrement les dents sont
extrêmement usées c'est à dire que les
dents il ne reste quasiment plus rien
des dents donc et pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu la classification des
mammifères classé hammami enfin arriver
à déterminer la classification d'un
fossile sans avoir les dents chez les
mammifères c'est quasiment impossible
et si vous le faites c'est certainement
que vous risquez de vous tromper parce
que les dents c'est la base de la
classification de chaque espèce a un
patron morphologiques dentaire qui lui
est propre et les espèces plus les
espèces se ressemble évidemment et plus
ce patron va être aux proches donc
donc classer cette espèce là sans les
dents déjà c'est soit une prouesse soit
quelque chose qui va pas donc ce qu'ils
ont utilisé du coup vu qu'il n'avait pas
de danse et un scanner et grâce au
scanner comme comme pour un scanner
médical ils ont fait des radios et ils
ont vu qu'en fait les racines de ses
dents étaient alors sur un troisième
prémolaires ses racines été fusionnées
et ça selon eux c'est un caractère qu'il
parent que cette espèce européenne
partagerait avec l'homme mais pas avec
les grands singes les autres grands
singes et idem c'est un caractère qui
est extrêmement discutable parce que
déjà tous les hominidés tous les
homininés non pas des racines de la
troisième prémolaires fusionner donc
pour en faire un caractère typique des
homininés c'est quand même embêtant
et en plus les chez certains spécimens
de chimpanzés on voit des racines de la
troisième prémolaires fusionner
donc a priori c'est un caractère qui
serait relativement variable donc
donc il ya fort peu de chances que ce
soit un caractère qui soient fiables
ce caractère sur les racines et le
dernier caractère qui l'utilisent c'est
la petite taille des canines et la
petite taille des canines
alors je le dis avec ça et là entre opus
c'est à caractère qui est distinctif des
des homininés mais c'est un caractère
qu'on retrouve aussi occasionnellement
chez des grands singes chez des grands
singes fossiles et particulièrement en
europe à l'époque il ya un grand sage
qui s'appelle our aurait au pit et cus
qui a été découvert en italie et il a
des toutes petites canine donc il n'est
pas impossible que sur la base de ces
caractères sur les racines et sur les
canines ils soient arrivés à une
conclusion qui fait de cette espèce grec
a nominé mais que cette conclusion soit
fauche et en réalité est en réalité
c'est ce que beaucoup pensent
aujourd'hui beaucoup de mes collègues
pensent aujourd'hui est ce que tu penses
que que l'article de plats soient enfin
que plos one le peer review a dû être
plus sévère ou ou c'est juste
enfin qu'est ce que tu viens tu penses
que l'article était bien mais c'est
simplement un truc de spécialistes et
que c'est pas alors ils ont ils ont bien
fait de le laisser passer ou pas je
pense que cet article aurait mérité
d'être de passer si en fait il ya des
lacunes ya vraiment des lacunes assez
évidente dans le raisonnement est la
première d'entre elles c'est ce qu'il
manque ce qu'on appelle une analyse
cladistique ou même n'importe quel type
d' analyse phylogénétique sans rentrer
dans le détail
dire qu'une espèce appartient à telle ou
telle famille et en particulier quand il
s'agit des homininés et qu'on essaie de
faire de d'argumenter sur le fait que
notre espèce et la première mairie n'est
dire faire faire une inférence pareil
sur la classification d'une espèce sans
faire ce qu'on appelle l'analyste ni
stylo génétique c'est un peu comme
donner le résultat d'une équation sans
jamais faire les calculs